geht nicht davor stellt sich gefühlt
haben
jazz kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video und wie ihr vielleicht
wisst es auf youtube mittlerweile schon
so eine art tradition dass man sich
irgendwann zu irgendeinem zeitpunkt in
seiner youtube karriere mal seine alten
videos anschaut und die nochmal nach
kommentiert bisschen habe ich mir
gedacht dass ich das auch mal mache ich
habe mir mein erstes video auf einem
kanal runtergeladen das war damals eine
adventure merkwürdig wenn max
zusammengespielt hat zwar nicht mal alle
erstes video auf youtube weil ich davor
schon mal ein video von max aufgetaucht
bin aber das erste beim kanal
das wird auf jeden fall sehr
unterhaltsam was geht ab wir sind
building minecraft sind einfach viel zu
laut
ich finde ich war sehr nervig findet
bitte ich bisher zu recht einfach diese
minecraft ist was drin
diese soundqualität leute das ist
stickig gucken was wir zerstören können
die macht über die minecraft sounds
leise alter
wir haben bei dieser map katastrophal
gefällt ich hab den weg niemals gelöst
dass das schwein benennen das heißt
jetzt damals auch schon nutzbar sei
nicht sehr wichtig als niemand hat in
den kommentaren den namen congo after
für das schweinchen vorgeschlagen und
die so direkt nicht so cool das nichts
zu tun haben wir haben uns schon jetzt
mein ganzes leben lang hat sie ihn schon
bevor ihn kann
hier müssen wir ansetzen
wir müssen erst einen runterschubsen hat
er gesagt
die deine und zitrus runterschubsen ich
musste ganz ganz kurz davor gehen was
einfallen richtige geistesblitz die
besten einfach volvo etabliert ist also
die diode variante von volvo ist kein
peter oben vielleicht werden general der
anweisungen sollen dieses verdammte
pickel darunter schubsten was macht max
box mich runter springt hinterher so
hoch da haben wir einfach schon gefällt
das war wieder komplett versagt er war
auf diese witze waren so schlecht da
juli wo die neue variante von wolf das
tragische ist dass ich mir diese sprüche
das finde ich brauche es gedacht habt
tatsächlich vor nicht allzu langer zeit
vor zwei jahren dachte dass es wirklich
cool so was zu sagen na ja ich hab ich
habe mich umgehört
ohne wilsmann wie max ist einfach
ignoriert ich würde ja noch versucht die
eisentür mit dem rechtsklick zu öffnen
hier an
so schlecht kann ich das doppelte dafür
ist das komplizierte richtig schick das
nicht ist eine truppe also ich
reinkommen ihr lieber nicht wirklich was
mache ich dann
wir müssen wahrscheinlich doch in den
brennraum des schreckens wo das rätsel
ist verdammt bist du bereit
es ist ein heftiges rätsel hier liegt
das rätsel habe ich gut gelöst da
erinnere ich mich daran dadurch eine
gute idee ich war schon mal kräftig
total schlecht aber bei diesem rätsel
ich eine gute idee ich habe ein ziemlich
über über ahnung
diese dumme fans schon mal kurz
erklärung dass mit der webstyle bedeutet
dass ich dachte die aufgabe wäre
abgeschmiert
ich gehe davon aus dass die aufnahme
abgeschmiert ist abgebrochen ist und
sich niemand trotzdem weiter auf
so nach dem motto ja vielleicht klappt's
ja vielleicht läuft es ja doch ich war
so fertig in so vielen verschiedenen
sichten c geistes meisten hier ist der
schlüssel für die nächste tür
88 ich habe zufällig eintauschen
es ist einfach auf den knopf drücken ich
hab mal alle es genug in die kommentare
zeigen kann ich den neuen crafter und
aufgeführt eine milliarde so konnte
niemand verpassen dass wir gerade places
in dem raum da hatten
love love love love love love
die hauen es sind allerdings aus stark
das auftragsbuch macht das alter hier
sind die monster drei tage später schon
auf die uhr geschaut
15 minuten alt da wurde auch keinen
einzigen cut gesetzen der ganzen
aufnahme ja ich würde sagen dann war's
das für diese folge nächsten morgen
kanals diese weiterhin haut rein das
war's ich habe mir mein erstes video
angeschaut
es hat mir sehr wehgetan ich hoffe ihr
könnt ein bisschen drüber lachen